un picasso contre un autre et tout le
monde est ravi le ministre de la culture
l'heureux propriétaire et les marchands
de tableaux les noces de pierrette très
beau période bleue de picasso pourront
sortir de france après leur mise aux
enchères prochainement mais nous gardons
la célestine george p vous souvenez vous
nous vous présentions il ya peu de temps
un tableau de picasso hyper protégé les
noces de pierrette ce tableau devenus
libres de sortir de france se vendra aux
enchères à la fin du mois 400 millions
de francs un record mais une perte pour
le patrimoine aussi jack lang a t'il
négocier le droit de sortie des noces de
pierrette contre un autre tableau de
picasso de la même fameuse période bleue
la célestine un chef-d'oeuvre historique
un thème que picasso reprendra toute sa
vie beau cadeau pour nos musées
nationaux
mais prenez vos calculettes et
considérer la faire réaliser par
monsieur ross suédois vivant à paris il
y a un an et demi ils achètent les noces
aux environs de 25 millions il va les
revendre 400 millions et le tableau
qu'il offre en échange la célestine ne
lui a coûté que 100 millions auprès du
marchand français didier imbert bénéfice
du suédois et 275 millions
qui dit mieux et que faire quand aucun
de nos musées ne peut rivaliser
si le ministre la culture interdisait la
sortie des noces de pires
les musées nationaux n'avait ni est
notre pire est finie la cedh estime et
le marché de l'art était brutalement
associés et je crois qu'on perdait sur
deux plans nous perdions une grande
bagarre et nous perdions une chambre
développement du marché de l'art en
somme tout le monde est content il faut
bien se rendre à l'évidence l'art
aujourd'hui c'est surtout une question
de marché
ce n'est pas l'entremetteuse célestine
qui nous contredira